is there someone you know that that  happened with what happened I want to be  in the know you're laughing  I'm just saying there's a lot of girls  out there that move mad they have men at  home their man don't know they don't  know do you think that they're cheating  because they're married or in a  relationship with their second choice  and it wasn't who they really wanted I  feel like  um when it comes to relationships people  um lose that drive when the years like  start to pile up people stop being like  as affectionate as romantic like going  that extra mile I think that's what  drives people apart and maybe that's  when one person might step out you think  women get bored  and then she I feel like if you get  bored then you haven't picked the right  person  or maybe it could be attention like  you're like the person someone else has  given you more attention than your  partner which you don't know that but  waiting your eye in the first place  because something is happening yeah